[Music]
all right well we have reached the end
of the regularly scheduled uh
programming content and if you'll
indulge me for a few more minutes i know
it's been a
wonderful long conversation but uh with
time dilation perhaps we'll be able to
play around with that perception for the
listeners but um if you'll indulge me
i'd like to go into the impossible with
dr shep doltman answering my three
patented thrilling three final questions
of existential reality
the first question that i ask all my
listeners is what would you put in your
ethical will not your material will
so in the hebrew tradition which i
partake in
there's a document called the zava ah
which is an ethical will and it's meant
to convey and articulate an inheritance
of wisdom to
not your only your biological errors but
your ideological heirs which of which
there are many
they're not only for jews they're for
president obama made one and you can
find them all online i want to ask you
what would you put in an ethical will uh
encapsulating the wisdom
of you know kind of the the the
inheritance that you'd most like to
leave to those that come after you
wow it's really a wonderful wonderful
question
um a few things come to mind
one
is uh
it sounds a little odd but you know
don't take no
for an answer i mean no is always an
opportunity
and you can do it in a nice way
uh you can do it in an ethical way
but you can always push the boundaries
and
as long as you do it in the right way a
no can be very powerful
so you know you know
you can't do this no i'm going to try to
do this anyway so it's very important to
understand that
the other thing i'd say is
is uh
allowing
yourself to depend on others
is a very important thing if you want to
do something really grand
you can't do everything yourself
and and uh believing in and creating an
environment
for for other people
to do their work
is
is a very important legacy yeah those
are the things that i'm thinking of at
the moment
thank that is wonderful let us go to the
second of the thrilling three final
questions
[Music]
a kind of call back to the progenitor of
the name of this podcast arthur c clarke
you'll find out about why that is in
just a bit but arthur c clarke um in his
famous uh movie that was turned into a
movie right his book that was turned
into movie space odyssey there are these
mysterious monoliths that kind of
populate
uh the the universe on earth and on the
moon in space etc etc and we're not
really sure what they are
they could be a warning they could be a
weapon they could be a time capsule
which is the way i like to think about
them when i ask you if you had a time
capsule that would
outlive you not past your
mortal coil you know years of 120 in the
biblical sense but if you were able to
reach you know out to a billion years
not you personally but you could put
anything any information
whatsoever on a monolith that would last
for so long what would it be uh what
would it comprise
scientifically speaking is is this like
a a bit of information
that goes
yeah it would be you could engrave it
you could put a a cd rom on it you could
put a correlator tape on it from you
could do whatever you want with it it's
going to last for a billion years and
it's meant to convey what human beings
had accomplished not just you maybe
specifically but what the human
civilization had accomplished to some
futuristic alien species
wow
[Music]
well i i guess you know
i i would put uh
an image
of
the light bending around a black hole
with
the
right proportions so that the
people many many billions of years from
now would know that
we had understood
that light bends around
a black hole because i'm sure that black
holes are
[Music]
or would be understood by alien
civilizations to be
as as crazy as we think
they are and so
giving them some understanding that we
knew what those were and that we had
imaged one
uh
i think
they would look at that and say they had
it going on they knew what was going on
they they accomplished something
all right
all right here we go the final thrilling
three uh third question which relates to
one of arthur c clarke's
famous laws he had a law that you
probably heard any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
so you and eht are performing a type of
magic he also said something i love to
pull out on my department chair from
time to time he said for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
and then he said his third law was the
only way of discovering the limits of
the possible is to venture a little way
past them into the impossible that's the
origin of the name of this podcast
so i asked you uh kind of advice to your
former self what mysterious aspect of
your life perplexed you as a 20 year old
a 30 year old
and yet eventually provided you with
great great clarity um and sort of an
inciting incident that led to a
breakthrough to make you who you are
today so advice to your former self what
what kind of pushed you into the
impossible
well i guess i i would say that
this realization that failure is okay
that that you really do need to fail
in order to understand what it is you
want to do
and how you want to do it and what's
possible i mean if you're not if you're
not failing
then you're
you're not testing the boundaries
and i think it's hard for people to fail
it's really difficult because we're
always told
you know don't fail like don't mess up
you know do this eat your eat your
breakfast you know
like i failed and get my breakfast but
but but in in your career
uh
failing is just is so important
and and to embrace that
it's it's antithetic it's kind of
antithetical but to embrace that
um leads to a lot of very very
interesting things
so that's my
if i had to go back and talk to myself
i'd say fail more
i always get
tickled by the fact that you know
there's this google engram
searcher you can search on phrases and
how often they've been used and the
context of different phrases that if you
search the phrase
in quotes that it was the best thing
that ever happened to me and then you
ask well what sentence came right before
that sentence and it's always i failed i
got fired you know i uh you know i lost
this you know this prize you know
whatever and and because of that it
leads to great growth and you know
there's there's a saying i forget maybe
it's a rabbi maybe it's yogi berra who
knows the difference and it's uh you
know there is no success without failure
you really cannot achieve greatness
without risking when
and that also entails failure as part of
the success process so shep dolmen
an incredible interview
a really wonderfully vulnerable side of
you which will delight uh my audience
but also very technical nerdy and fun uh
which will delight you know the other
half of my audience uh so i do want to
express my deep gratitude on behalf of
myself my listeners uh for going into
the impossible with yours truly and
spending so much year valuable time on
me uh and i wish you the best in your
success and and uh offer you our deepest
gratitude for opening with your
colleagues this phenomenal view of the
universe
well thanks very much brian it's been a
pleasure